in the opening scene we are introduced
to Norway's most successful Headhunter
Roger Brown a Headhunter is a person who
identifies potential candidates and
recommends them to various companies
apart from this Roger also has a
peculiar hobby of stealing artwork from
his clients he describes himself as a
short person who makes up for his height
with his good looks and money Roger is
married to a tall and attractive woman
named Diana who is unaware of his
illegal activities and thinks that he
gained all his wealth through
inheritance despite Diana's strong
desire to have a child Roger is not yet
prepared for Parenthood as part of their
routine Roger drops Diana off at her Art
Gallery where she works alongside other
men this triggers Roger's insecurities
fearing that the other tall and handsome
men may lure Diana away from him so to
maintain her happiness Roger often buys
expensive gifts for her he also has a
secret mistress named lot after dropping
off Diana he meets up with his mistress
and engages in a physical relationship
with her that day lot suggests going out
for dinner she wants to introduce him to
some other people however Roger firmly
rejects the idea and denies any deeper
connection between them abruptly ending
their relationship in the next scene
Roger is at his client Pathfinders
company conducting an interview with a
candidate named Lander for the CEO
position during the interview Roger
brings out an expensive painting and
asks if Lander is aware of its value in
response the latter reveals that he
himself possesses a million dollar
painting in this house as their
conversation progresses Roger finds out
that no one is present at Lander's
residence during the daytime this makes
him determined to steal the expensive
painting and make it his following the
interview Roger contacts his crime
partner ove who works at a surveillance
company he informs of about Lander and
the valuable painting in his house
realizing that there is a new Target of
discreetly gains access to the control
room and deactivates the security system
at Landers residence meanwhile Roger
breaks into the house and swaps the
original artwork with account
later he withdraws some money so that he
can buy another expensive gift for his
wife just then he receives a call from
his accountant who warns him about the
impending risk of bankruptcy if he
continues spending recklessly the scene
then cuts to Diana's art gallery opening
where she introduces Roger to Kloss
grieve a former executive from the GPS
tech company Haute after a brief
conversation with him Roger who is
currently searching for a CEO for
Pathfinder realizes that Kloss could be
a potential candidate he knows that
Pathfinder and Haute are competitors but
despite this he arranges a meeting with
Kloss for the next day after the event
Diana reveals that Kloss has recently
inherited a painting which is believed
to be worth millions hearing this Roger
sees an opportunity to alleviate his
financial troubles and plans to steal
the painting he then contacts elf and
arranges a meeting to discuss the same
the next morning Diana brings up the
topic of having a child once again and
reminds Roger that he has been denying
her for seven years annoyed Roger
angrily responds that it will take seven
more years if she continues to nag him
about it following this he meets elf who
initially expresses reluctance to carry
out the job due to his recent engagement
with a Russian girl however Roger
manages to persuade him by saying that
the painting is worth millions with it
he can buy whatever he wants for his new
life later in the day Roger meets Kloss
at a restaurant to discuss the job
during their conversation Roger uses his
usual tactics to gather more information
about cloths they spend the remainder of
the day together sharing meals and
playing squash this extended interaction
allows Roger to gather the information
that he needs he discovers that Kloss
was formerly a member of track a
specialized unit focused on tracking
individuals and had even won the
European military pentathlon in addition
Kloss played a role in the development
of a nanotechnology GPS tracking gel for
hode which is difficult to remove
despite recognizing the significant
risks involved Roger decides to proceed
with his plan to steal the painting on
the planned day of the robbery Roger
with the help of of covertly and traits
classes residents and swaps the genuine
painting with a fake one but before
leaving Roger notices children playing
outside the house which unexpectedly
causes a change of heart regarding his
stance on having children he calls Diana
to share the news that he is now ready
to start a family surprisingly while
making the call he hears a ringing phone
from koss's bedroom on investigating
further Roger shockingly discovers his
wife's cell phone next to Claus's bed
suggesting a potential Affair between
them enraged he immediately returns home
and confronts her about it but Diana
pretends that she might have just left
her phone at the art gallery the next
day Kloss has a meeting with Pathfinder
but Roger finds it difficult to
concentrate as his thoughts revolve
around his wife's alleged infidelity
with Kloss in an act of retaliation he
informs Kloss that He is uncertain about
recommending him for the position after
work Roger confronts Diana once again
and tells her that he will make sure
Claus does not get any job in all of
Norway hearing this her expression
quickly changes but she meant to
maintain her composure the following
morning as Roger prepares to leave for
work he discovers oh flying Motionless
in his car alarmed he tries to wake his
partner up but to no avail after a while
Roger finds a poisonous syringe embedded
in the car seat this means that he was
the intended victim and that ove
accidentally sat on the syringe while
trying to steal the car filled with
alarm Roger places of his body in the
trunk and drives towards a nearby lake
with the intention of disposing of it
there however when he tosses the body
into the water oath suddenly regains
Consciousness indicating that the poison
did not take full effect this frightens
Roger even more so he quickly dives into
the lake and pulls the semi-conscious of
back into the car after driving him to
his place Roger lays him in bed and
starts blabbering about his wife's
illicit Affair of who is in a lot of
pain
urges Roger to call 9-1-1 but the latter
refuses saying he doesn't want to
involve the police instead he retrieves
some milk from the refrigerator which
can neutralize the effects of the poison
in the process Roger discovers gun in
the fridge and takes it along with the
milk when he returns to the room of has
another gun in hand he threatens Roger
to call an ambulance and even fires some
warning shots in a state of panic Roger
accidentally pulls the trigger of his
own gun which ends up killing of
terrified Roger quickly exits the
house only to find Kloss who has been
trailing him sensing that the man is
behind all of this Roger immediately
flees towards his car and speeds away
during his Escape Roger realizes that
cost may have employed hote's GPS gel
tack to track him as a result he
switches cars abandoning his own vehicle
for oves moreover he throws his clothes
in a nearby lake and changes into spare
clothing from ove's uniform seeking
Refuge Roger arrives at a farm where ove
used to reside there he rents a cabin
from an owner and then starts looking
for a place where he can hide the stolen
painting shortly after he runs into a
toilet outside and hides the painting in
its old dusty ceiling in the next scene
Kloss follows Roger to the farm
accompanied by his dog after a brief
conversation with the owner Kloss heads
towards the cabin where Rogers staying
the latter spots him from the toilet and
with nowhere to go he hides inside the
dirty pit of the toilet after a while
Kloss arrives at the same toilet and
searches it thoroughly but finds nothing
and leaves pile of is basically
camouflage for Roger as night falls
Roger comes out from the toilet and
rushes towards his car however he is
unable to start the vehicle due to
apparent tempering of its wires by Kloss
left with no alternative Roger decides
to take the farm owner's tractor to
access it he needs the key so he
discreetly sneaks into the owner's house
inside Roger is horrified to discover
the lifeless body of the
despite the Grim scene he retrieves the
keys from the owner's pocket and
hurriedly returns to the Tractor just as
he is about to board it kloss's dog
detects his presence and initiates an
attack in the ensuing chaos Roger
inadvertently impales the dog on the
tractor's Forks killing it instantly
following this he drives away from the
farm while on the road Roger notices a
vehicle trailing behind him believing
that Kloss is still pursuing him he
drives erratically leading to his fall
from the tractor it is later revealed
that the pursuer was a stranger who only
wanted to offer help Roger then awakens
in a hospital bed and upon glancing out
the window he spots kloss's car which
unsettles him determined to escape he
makes an attempt but some police
officers who were stationed outside
quickly apprehend him during this
encounter Roger learns that the police
mistakenly believe him to be of and they
have arrested him on the grounds of
killing the farmer hence he stops
resisting and simply cooperates with the
authorities while on route to the police
station the officers pull over to block
a reported stolen truck the driving cops
episode to take a look at the situation
but the truck doesn't slow down seeing
this Roger realizes that Kloss is still
following him he has changed his clothes
and completely altered his appearance
but somehow the freak knows his every
move after thinking for a while Roger
finally realizes that Kloss has
installed a Tracker in his hair in the
form of a GPS gel this was put there by
none other than his own wife Diana after
learning all of this A desperate Roger
warns the officers about the imminent
danger posed by the truck but is please
go unheard moments later Kloss hits the
police car sending it hurtling off a
cliff and causing the death of all the
officers after a brief period of
unconsciousness Roger wakes up to find
himself trapped upside down between the
lifeless bodies of all the officers soon
after Kloss approaches the scene to
confirm Roger's demise in order to save
himself our hero fans death until clost
departs after this he drags himself out
from the car unlocks his handcuffs
shaves his head conceals his hair on one
of the deceased off officers and
exchanges clothing with another officer
whose body is disfigured thereby
simulating his own death with nowhere
else to run Roger goes to his
ex-mistress lot who lets him in while he
waits in a room lock goes to receive
first aid supplies during this Roger
notices a hot pen indicating that lot is
also working for Kloss enraged he
quickly confronts her at gunpoint
demanding the truth lot tries feigning
ignorance but when Roger prepares to
pull the trigger she finally speaks up
and reveals everything lot confesses
that Kloss isn't unemployed but he is
still secretly employed by Haute his
entire plan was to trick Roger so that
he could get the Pathfinder job and
steal valuable Technologies from them
lot admits that she was the one who put
the GPS gel in Roger's hair thereby
clearing Diana's name she also reveals
that she had invited him on a date
earlier so that she could introduce him
to Kloss however since Roger ended their
Affair Kloss fabricated a story
involving a million dollar painting as a
means to orchestrate a meeting through
Diana after learning all of this Roger
lowers his gun which gives her a chance
to attack him with a knife an intense
fight ensues between the two and Roger
ends up shooting her in self-defense
Roger then returns home and confesses
everything to Diana who also apologizes
for her affair with Kloss Diana
questions if Roger had feelings for lot
to which he responds in the negative she
calls him stupid for stealing art just
to buy her things as their conversation
unfolds Roger admits that he was afraid
of losing Diana so he went to Great
Lengths to keep her happy he also
confesses that he was apprehensive about
having a child because he feared Diana
would prioritize the child over him
after these heartfelt confessions the
couple addresses their issues and shares
an emotional hug the next morning Roger
visits a morgue in order to retrieve his
cut hair which could potentially link
him to the murders as soon as he leaves
Diana contacts Kloss seemingly to resume
their Affair after successfully stealing
the evidence from the forensic lab Roger
proceeds to ove's Residence to wipe out
the remaining incriminating evidence as
he cleans his finger class suddenly
confronts him apparently having tracked
the GPS gel within the cut hair he
boasts about Diana returning to him once
again in response Roger smirks provoking
class to aim his gun at him frustrated
by Roger's silence Kloss attempts to
shoot but fails Roger then delivers a
fatal blow to Kloss using a hidden
weapon revealing that Diana had resumed
her Affair only to tamper with Colossus
gun she had actually replaced live
rounds with blanks unbeknownst to Kloss
Roger has also activated security
cameras capturing footage of Kloss
engaging in a shootout Roger
strategically positions himself in a
blind spot near ove's lifeless body
where the cameras cannot see him after
shooting claws to death Roger places the
gun in ov's hand and sneaks out of the
crime scene through a window the footage
along with fabricated evidence by Roger
suggests that oven Kloss were art
thieves who murdered the farm owner lot
and ultimately killed each other after a
dispute in the aftermath of these events
the police including the esteemed
detective named braid spare Overlook
minor inconsist instances such as the
time above's death conflicting with the
video footage because bread knows that
leaving the case unsolved would harm his
growing reputation in the final scene we
see Roger and Diana who are about to
become parents Roger is back to work
where he proceeds to hire Lander as the
new CEO of Pathfinder company despite
initially rejecting him subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching